congrats on a fantastic game now that
some time has passed how are you feeling
about being evicted what emotions are
you feeling right now pride happiness
sadness all of it
oh my god i am feeling so many things um
i was evicted during a double um so i'm
still kind of in shock i'm still
processing the fact that i will never
step foot in the big brother house again
um i feel like i wasn't able to say
proper goodbyes i wasn't able to leave
people stuff
um so i'm kind of sad but i'm also
relieved to not be in that stressful
high pressured environment anymore and
then i feel an overwhelming sense of
pride i mean i was i was part of the
cookout i was part of the only alliance
the only six person alliance in big
brother history to make it to final six
and that's pretty monumental so
i'm happy i'm content with my
performance this season and i don't
regret much
this season of big brother will make
history the first black winner ever and
you were a part of making that history
what do you think this will mean to so
many people seeing themselves reflected
out there
okay well honestly one of the main
reasons that i felt encouraged enough to
apply to big brother in the first place
is because i saw
devon bailey and david
um in season 22 and how they
pledged to have each other's back and
that really gave me
the confidence that i needed to see
myself winning this game because
historically people who look like me are
usually the first to go
um
so hopefully you know
more young black women more young south
asian women because i'm also indian um
can see me
and
are happy with how i represented
um
and i hope that they have the same
experience watching me and the same
realization watching me as i had with
devon bailey and david in season 22. um
and i think it's really just important
for representation purposes
to see that the black community is not a
monolith between the six of us we are
all so different
um
and yes i
i hope that the diversity this season
um
with you know 50 of our cast being
people of color but also the diversity
within the cookout was refreshing for
america to see
do you think aza made the biggest
mistake ever do you think who do you
think is the next house guest to be
evicted if not aza
okay um
maybe azam made the biggest mistake ever
or maybe
she didn't i don't know um what she sees
for herself in this game
i personally think that
oz's hoh was a waste on me because i i
mean
as soon as tiffany left i was like
oz is probably my best bet of winning
this game if i were to sit next to her
in final two so i was not gonna put her
on the block i wasn't gonna touch her if
i had won hoh i was really planning on
taking her fart in this game i wanted to
split up the guys
i'm not sure if the guys can say the
same
um
so i do believe that it was a wasted hoh
and
i think that she will be following me um
but if not her if she is able to win
that veto and she's the sole vote to
evict
i think i will probably see kyland next
what was the hardest moment for you of
the season being in the big brother
house isn't easy we're always warned to
expect the unexpected was it harder than
you thought
um
big bro okay so the game that i intended
to play was different than the game that
i actually played once i saw that there
were five others of me i kind of had to
recalibrate and reconfigure my strategy
in this game
i did want to come in hot i wanted to
come in
and be messy and chaotic but because of
the cookout
i felt like i couldn't um because the
stakes were so much higher at that point
um
what was i gonna say oh yes um
the hardest part of the game for me was
having to balance
what would have benefited my personal
interests in the game and what benefited
the cookout
for example having to send
derek x holm convincing him that he
shouldn't play in chopping block
roulette because i was more in danger of
going home that week than him i didn't
want him to win i didn't want him to
take claire down at that point alyssa
would have been our only option and we
didn't know how likely sb was to put up
one of her closest allies at that time
um
so i i do
i mean keeping dx would have
been excellent for my personal game he
would have never targeted me he would
have never put me on the block but he
had to go home
because
the cookout
who knows if the cookout could have
taken him out
um and here he was being handed to us on
a silver platter and for selfish reasons
i didn't want to give anyone else in the
cookout the benefit of being able to say
that they sent home dx
who is arguably
the strongest competitive threat of this
season
um so i just didn't want to give any
other member the opportunity to add that
to their resume and that is yet another
reason why dx had to go home but because
he was one of the closest people in the
house to me i did feel very conflicted
guilty and emotional that week and that
was probably the hardest moment of the
game for me
who do you want to stay in the house and
who do you want to join you next in jury
um
i
okay
if big d or kailand were to join me in
jury i would not be mad um i feel like
there were numerous instances
when highland
acted more selfishly than the other
members of the cookout for example sarah
beth was supposed to go home that very
first week of jury and what does kailan
do
he wins the hoh even though he was
supposed to throw it to either aza or
tiff so they could have taken that shot
against sb
um and that's just one example of kailan
kind of
doing his own thing and going rogue and
us having to
overcompensate for that so that he
wouldn't be the biggest target in the
house and people would not be gunning
for him
um so because of that and
another thing is i didn't question
kyle's loyalty to the cookout but i
always kind of wondered is kailyn
setting himself up just in case the
cookout fails and i think he was um i
think he was being i think he was being
very diligent about that um so for that
reason i would not mind if thailand you
know
follows me um and then with big d big d
made it very clear that he wanted to be
sent home at final five he was
just there for fame he was just there
for the money and that's kind of a slap
in the face to the game
um which is a game that i love and
respect so much
so
for those reasons yeah i'd like to see
either kailan or big d follow me
you